hey everyone welcome welcome welcome
into another exciting edition of Market
takes I know you could have been
anywhere in the world but you're here
with me and I appreciate that I'm Dion
Ronan reporter at the Wall Street
Journal today we are breaking down the
latest pce personal consumption
expenditures report it's all about
inflation this is the fed's favored
inflation uh reading and we are going to
get into just what it said what it means
and what this tells us about the market
about the FED about the economy all
those things moving forward so we're
going to talk about what the report said
how that compared to expectations we're
going to talk about the big takeaways
from this report I think this report had
some very interesting takeaways and
we're seeing the market and investors do
some very interesting things right now
today is one of my favorite days we get
this report where the response from the
market doesn't really make a lot of
sense but it tells you a lot about
what's happening in the world so I'm
very excited about what we're going to
get into today uh we're going to check
in with the market talk to you about
what we're seeing in stocks bonds
currencies Commodities all that good
stuff talk about how this report aligns
with other data we've seen specifically
other inflation data uh but some other
things and then we're going to talk
about what comes next because you know
here at Market takes we are always
looking forward even though it is
backward looking data so listen let's
get into it let's talk about what we saw
in the report this pce report today came
out let's throw a chart up here on your
screen first of all so you can see what
I'm seeing this is the longterm going
back to 2021 right and that's important
because the number we got today pce
inflation came in 3% year-over-year that
was the lowest that we had seen since
all the way back in 2021 you look there
this report the lowest we had seen in
quite some time so this is important
because it shows the trajectory of
inflation coming back down as you can
see there inflation was kind of starting
to pick back up a little bit on this
inflation gauge you saw it Rising back
towards 4% well it is now fallen back to
3% we got 3% inflation and that is big
for the report that's big for the FED
we'll talk about all that in just a
moment but really this chart that you're
seeing on your screen just illustrating
the overall change that we have seen in
inflation coming back down doing what
the Federal Reserve wants what Shoppers
Wants What markets want uh this really
this trend this trajectory is a good
thing now when talking about the FED fed
talks about PC but the FED likes to
focus on core PC when you strip out
those food and energy prices which can
be very volatile so let's throw that up
here on your screen as well take a look
at core PC and again doing a similar
thing right but unlike that overall pce
number and that chart that we were just
looking at you see this one just coming
consistently down you see it's moving
downward and again last month was higher
than the month before and now we are
moving lower and so you got about
3.5% pce uh for the quarter or sorry for
the month uh and that compared to
expectations 3 and. half% 2% so right on
the nose of expectations economists had
expected for inflation to move lower and
to continue moving lower into this month
and that's exactly what we're seeing we
are seeing inflation decline or come
down on both a core and overall basis
meaning oil and gas prices are coming
down food prices are coming down but so
is everything else and when I say coming
down I don't mean the prices are getting
lower I just mean they are rising at a
slower Pace we still do have 3%
inflation in the economy and that's what
you're seeing right there up on your
screen core PC for those things like
housing like overall prices that's still
Rising about 3 and a half% but much
slower than that seven or 5 and a half%
level that we saw in the middle of 2022
so again this chart just illustrating
that overall longterm when you take a
big picture look at the economy
inflation is slowing down not Rising as
fast it has been so let's talk about the
big takeaways from this report right the
big headline takeaway that everyone is
talking about that you're probably
seeing in headlines seeing on your
Twitter feed or excuse me your X feed if
you will uh is that inflation has slowed
down this is the the slowest inflation
has been since early 2021 and that's the
big picture right we've seen this
consistent decline in inflation slowing
on an overall basis that had been giving
initially stock and bond prices a big
Tailwind over the past month we have
seen stocks rise higher we've seen those
bond yields fall which means bond prices
are falling that's a good thing
generally if you're an investor because
you were seeing really an increase in
prices and what people are doing is
they're betting that the Federal Reserve
is going to start cutting interest rates
that's going to loosen up the economy
that's going to mean that these
businesses are making more money people
are going out spending more and that's
another thing that we got in this report
is some indications we're going to get
into that in just a moment but the big
picture takeaway from this report
inflation is slowing down and that has a
lot of consequences for the overall
economy for markets stocks bonds all
kinds of assets and that's the big
picture CPI inflation the other big
inflation gauge that's more popular with
the general public more watched that
fell to 3.2% last month after being 3.7%
the previous month so when we look at
these reports we're seeing the same
thing we were seeing for a while sort of
CPI higher than PC and that's still true
a little bit but then for a while we got
CPI lower than PC and there was some
Wonder like okay are some of the things
in the pce report the way that the PC
report measures inflation is that
potentially telling us that infl is
actually higher than we expect well
that's why one one report or one month
does not make a trend the trend is still
telling US inflation is coming down it's
slowing right the FED funds Futures
Market shows that investors are really
taking a lot from this and when we look
at the FED funds Futures Market I'm
looking at it right now you're seeing
expectation for the FED to start cutting
rates by its second meeting of the year
we've got about a 40% chance of the FED
cutting rates a more excuse me a 44%
chance now looking at the market live on
CME uh the CME market and that's the the
FED fund Futures Market that's showing
and now it's back down to 40 anyway I
shouldn't try to keep up with this live
but seeing a 40% chance of a cut by the
FED in March that is huge because the
FED has not said we're going to cut
rates the FED hasn't said we're ready to
start cutting rates as long as inflation
behaves what the FED has said is
inflation is too high we need to get it
back to 2% not 3% 2% and then we can
start cutting back rates reducing rates
but the market is getting out ahead of
that the FED is or the market is saying
no no no again we don't believe you we
don't believe that you're going to keep
rates this High we think you guys are
going to start cutting very quickly very
soon Market is seeing no likelihood of a
rate hike this month at it or sorry next
month at its meeting in December 96%
chance the FED doesn't raise rates at
its meeting on December 13th that's up
from 74% just a month ago so the market
is saying rate hikes are out that's over
that story is done rate cuts are what's
coming and rate Cuts loosen up the
economy makes it less expensive to
borrow money gives people more money in
their pocket gives businesses cheaper
financing so they can borrow money for
less and that makes their balance sheets
look better that means they've got more
to go out and hire do things like that
so again we are seeing the the markets
really price in that all this is what's
coming from the FED not in a long time
not way down the road not in 2025 but
next year and really just in a couple
months at its second meeting of the year
in March that is big uh investors
pricing rate cuts into June is what we
were talking about just a couple weeks
ago and that was a huge Trend we had
seen investors really pricing out those
rate hikes potentially going into next
year so this is a massive sea change
what we've gotten today and what we've
gotten really over the past few weeks is
a huge sea change in terms of sentiment
and expectations for what comes from the
fed and if you watch Market takes if you
follow the markets you know that the
central Banks and the FED are everything
that's what it's all about that's what's
moving everything and what we have seen
over the past few weeks and in a big way
today is a pricing of more rate Cuts
pricing out of rate hikes that's big
speaking of let's take a look at what's
going on in the markets right now want
to throw up here on your screen wsj.com
and what we're seeing from the markets
and if you notice there the Dow is still
up but the NASDAQ which has been on a
tear up over 30% this year I think up
over 35 % year to date well it's a
little bit lower the S&P right around
flat but a little bit lower and I think
what you're seeing there is it could be
one of two things it could be a little
buy the rumors sell the news what that
means is when you start getting worried
oh the PC report's going to be strong
then investors kind of say okay well
based on what we've seen we think
inflation's going to keep coming down
let's buy stocks and then when it
actually comes in it's like okay well
we've seen the appreciation come in
we've seen prices move higher now we're
going to sell now we're going to get out
because we've realized what's happened
we've gotten the news we bought on the
rumor we expected for inflation to keep
coming down keep moving lower now we're
going to sell the news comes out and
confirms that our position was right
let's get out of these positions another
really interesting thing has been what
we've seen in the bond market and the
bond market is a bit of the same thing
you've got bond yields moving higher
which means prices are moving lower and
you saw this move really accelerate
after the release of this PC report so
you got the PC report being released
right around here you had the 10year
down at about 4.28 and now you see it
about 4.33 so bond yields were moving
higher really right after this report
came out and then the stock market which
opened up at 9:30 initially went higher
on the positive reading and then moved
lower and so we're seeing really the
stock market kind of follow the bond
market another interesting Market
happening that we saw today was
currencies right we're seeing the Euro
down in a big way which means the dollar
is up but take a look at the dollar
Index you were seeing just a big time
increase and that again you saw the
market sort of move down ahead of the
release and then that PC report came out
right around here and then you see it
just kind of move higher and now the
dollar Index is up pretty significantly
wsj dollar Index which measures the
dollar against more currencies that's up
in a big way as well so the dollar Index
when you look at the currency markets
they're still factoring in okay the
dollar is going to be stronger those
bond yields are going to be higher and
that's a very interesting thing when we
think about the way that inflation has
come down and really what we're seeing
from the market just kind of
illustrating the overall theme in
markets which is a bit of this
potentially buy the rumor sell the news
but it could be that maybe the market is
thinking okay maybe the fed's not going
to act as quickly as we think when
you're seeing these fed fund Futures
markets we're seeing investors really
pricing in a big move from the FED but
what you're seeing from the market is a
potential all right maybe this is a
little bit overdone maybe the rally is
going a little bit too far maybe
inflation's coming down but it's not
going to get to the fed's 2% Target as
quickly as everyone thinks could be that
or could just be a little buy the rumor
sell the news want to quickly point out
the FED has not said that they are on
board with rate Cuts they in fact fed
Governor Michelle Bowman said just
yesterday that quote her Baseline
economic Outlook continues to expect
that we will need to increase the
federal funds rate further to keep
policies efficiently restricted to bring
inflation to our 2% Target in a timely
way blah blah blah the big picture there
is that Michelle Bowman who's on the
fomc she's a voter she gets to a say in
what happens she's saying not only do I
not think rate Cuts I'm thinking rate
hikes I'm thinking we need to raise
rates again and this was just yesterday
so she had seen the CPI report she'd
seen unemployment continuing to kind of
go down these jobs numbers coming down
from their highs she's seen all the data
and likely she had seen this pce report
because remember the FED gets some of
this data early government officials get
that data early so those comments came
with the knowledge of what's happening
with the Slowdown inflation and she
still says we need to my Baseline
expectation meaning what she thinks will
happen if nothing crazy happens is that
we will need to increase the federal
funds rate that's big you also had po
come out and say the FED plans to hold
rates higher for some time you had New
York fed President John Williams out
today saying he doesn't really see rate
Cuts coming so the market could have
something maybe an unexpected surprise
the fed's next meeting December 13th
we'll be right here on Market takes
breaking all that down for you but again
the summary of economic projections of
that meeting will be huge and you'll
want to be right here we'll be breaking
all that down explaining what it all
means let's also throw since we're
talking about it let's put up the CPI
Consumer Price Index that's the other
inflation gauge this one the FED doesn't
watch as closely because they like the
way pce measures it but again you see
the same thing right and when I talk
about what fed Governor Michelle Bowman
had uh said yesterday she knows this
information she see an inflation come
down that's inflation about 3.2% on the
CPI but again moving back toward the
fed's 2% Target moving further away from
CPI Rose to as high as 9% back in
2022 we are very far from that right now
so that's just that chart just
illustrating what we've seen from CPI
similar to what we had seen from p CE uh
which is the report that we got out
today really quickly let's dig into the
report prices for goods decreased 3% for
the month where prices for services
increase by 0 2% this is big because we
are seeing Goods prices continue to
decline that was what really shot
inflation up used cars and trucks new
cars and trucks all those big durable
goods and things like that those pushed
inflation higher that's coming down
we're seeing Services inflation pick up
that's restaurants bars law firms uh you
know your dentist office all the those
things those services that people
provide we're seeing those prices go up
also food prices increase 2% Energy
prices decrease 2.6% so we're seeing oil
gas all those things those prices are
decreasing but we're seeing food prices
Services prices all those things Rising
the personal savings rate uh my man
Gregory Doo over at ey says that savings
rate continues to be unsustainably low
down to 3.8% that is well below the
long-term average actually up from May
but again well below the long-term
average most interesting thing I saw in
this report was the personal income
which is the personal income and outlays
Report the inflation adjusted disposable
personal income actually it had been
negative three months in a row July
through September well those were all
revised to zero and then October's
report showed an increase of 3% so
people actually were making a good deal
more money over the past few months than
initially anticipated so we could be
seeing even more money flowing through
the economy that could push inflation
higher but it also means that maybe
things aren't as dire as folks had
thought previously in terms of the way
that Americans wages are falling and
declining so according to the revisions
people have been making more money than
we thought the big thing to watch going
forward is going to be Services what
happens with services do those prices
keep rising and does that put pressure
on inflation moving back higher core
versus overall that's going to be
something to watch but the big picture
moving forward you're going to want to
watch Services we got a big services
report coming out next week snps uh
purchasing managers index on the
services side next Tuesday that's going
to be something you'll definitely want
to watch so the fed's favored gauge says
inflation is down to 3% says core is
down to three and a half% what are they
going to come out and tell us over the
next few days and what are they going to
tell us at their meeting on December
13th looks like inflation is coming back
towards Target but is clearly not there
yet if the FED is not planning to cut
rates next year in 2024 at least not
planning to cut rates at its second
meeting of the year they're going to
need to communicate that and that
communication could have a pretty
negative effect on stocks bonds all
kinds of other assets so you're going to
want to watch for fed communication
you're going to want to watch that fed
meeting all of those things one thing I
want to point out here and let's throw
another chart up here on your screen the
Atlanta fed feds wage growth tracker
that's shown a consistent move back down
and move lower in wages this is wage
growth right how much are folks wages
rising and growing that's been coming
down but again it stabilized in October
and that's the them that we saw we had
seen for a long time and this has been
consistent with the negative sentiment
that we've seen we've seen wages coming
down along with inflation but not moving
lower at the same pace of inflation so
people feeling like ah man I'm not
getting those same big raises I was I'm
not being able to demand as much of a
you know a big salary increase if I move
to a new job and this chart here the
Atlanta feds wage growth tracker really
just illustrating the way that wages
have moved lower overall when adjusted
for inflation we also had been seeing
that in the latest CPI report showed
real average earnings real average
weekly earnings fell in October uh we
had also seen that from the pce report
but again we've seen that reverse and
now real wages Rising moving up
inflation adjusted Wages that's big so
what comes next well like I told you
about that S&P Services PMI that comes
out on Tuesday the manufacturing version
will be out tomorrow you'll watch that
but the big one is going to be Services
next week definitely will be a big one
for inflation for sentiment of course
next week I will be out so I won't be
with you no Market takes but we will be
right back here on December 13th that's
fed day the fomc meeting we'll be
breaking down everything you hear from
pal what we hear in the statement the
summary of economic projections is going
to be a party so I hope you'll be with
us right here on Market takes before I
get out of here I got to plug my podcast
check it out wsj's take on the week we
are cutting through the noise to explain
the major business and financial news
that can move the markets also you can
make smarter investing decisions
subscribe listen wherever you get your
podcast Apple podcast Stitcher Spotify
whatever you do check out wsj's take on
the week hosted by me um and listen
that's going to do it for us here on
Market takes thank you so much for being
with us I am Dion Rolan reporter at the
Wall Street Journal we will see you next
time